good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
excuse me 40 good point I'm an important
group point excuse me I'm in boarding
Group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first-class passengers
first-class passengers only please next
our business-class passengers may now
board okay now we would like to welcome
our regal Alliance elite members regal
Alliance elite members okay now all
passengers with children anyone with
small children you may board now okay we
would like to continue boarding with
uniformed military personnel what my
kids this is for your service thank you
so much for your service god bless you
thank you for your service thank you for
your service
alright people in wheelchairs and
increase nuns rabbis Imam what why do
they get special treatment
assalamualaikum
I've never that's typical any old people
in wheelchairs with babies any old
religious people with military means
what's a military thank you for your
service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
war finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a bag so
you're not you're not gonna let me on
then
damnit
anyone who doesn't seem cranky drunk
people you will now be boarding any
drunk people hello oh hey Christian
yeah totally well you have your
favorites and I have my favorites okay
call you later
ciao ciao
for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
for teague-barred over there the
boarding Group one